okay some interesting uh so i actually
am glad to see on the david pakman show
subreddit this morning which is of
course
uh davidpakman.com r-e-d-d-i-t
a post asking is trump making a comeback
linking to a bunch of different polling
data which
seems to suggest that the huge lead that
biden maybe had about a month ago
may be narrowing now i i am going to
make the case
in the next segment that there is no
such lead it's not a question of it's
narrowing it's
it does not exist and i will make the
mathematical case i will make a
qualitative case for you as well and i'm
really glad that people on the subreddit
are discussing that
now also i don't want to spend a lot of
time on this
but there have been allegations
made that i eat mac and cheese with a
spoon which is really weird like if you
need a spoon for mac and cheese
it's really like a pasta soup i use
spoons only for
desserts and soups not for pasta um
and i i guess that in some circles this
is considered controversial but yes
i do eat uh mac and cheese with a fork
i think that that's the correct utensil
this is not really important given
everything that we have going on
but somehow this triggered a lot of
people in my audience and i really don't
know why so if that's something you want
to weigh in on
the place to do it would be the david
pakman show subreddit davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t but the focus here really
important to get back to the material
important
materially important things i don't know
when people talk about is trump making a
comeback
i don't know that donald trump needs to
make a comeback
and that's what i want to really focus
in on next